يتواعد الرئيس الروسي وبلادمه الرابوتين
بالرد على ما وصفه بالعدوان الغربي الجديد
على روسيا من خلال اوكرانيا وقال بوتين
خلال مشاركته في فعاليات الذكرى الثمانين
للانتصار في معركه
ان النازيه ظهرت مجددا وتهدد روسيا
بالدبابات الالمانيه
الان للاسف نرى ان اديولوجيه النازيه في
شكلها الحديث تشكل مره اخرى تهديدا مباشرا
لامن بلدنا نحن مضطرون مجددا لصد عدوان
الغرب الجماعي يتم تهديدنا مره اخرى
بدبابات الالمانيه المرصعه بالصلبان ومره
اخرى سيقاتلون روسيا على ارض اوكرانيا
بايد النازيين الجدد من اتباع بانديرا لكن
اولئك الذين يجرون الدول الغربيه بما في
ذلك المانيا الى حرب جديده مع روسيا ومن
يتوقعون الفوز على روسيا في ساحه المعركه
لا يفهمون على ما يبدو ان الحرب مع روسيا
ستكون مختلفه تماما قادرون على الرد عليهم
ولن يقتصر الامر على المدرعات